we thought we'd quiz you after the  bachelor finale Bennigan's and his new  fiance Lauren Bushnell headed over to  Jimmy Kimmel Live to play Jimmy's  version of the newlywed game the couple  were playing for dinnerware and gear  Mo's Ben the Phase II yoga pants you're  gonna have the pants also that Lauren  they'll be a nice thing thank you yeah  you could get married in those yes after  he's worn them they might be a little  puffy but the newly engaged couple got  three of the five questions right what  is each other's middle name Edward and  grace is that correct no name the  siblings Bryant Brett and Molly correct  and name of the childhood pet okay Ben  go ahead reveal Tessa Tessa was and  Kimmel even got Bachelor host Chris  Harrison in on the fun by helping him  come up with new scripts for the show on  this one all the women want to have sex  with Chris that's me why wouldn't they  know they know a bunch of unemployed  bachelors